Imamo kurs kursničke primude,
imamo pravna pravila,
kursna pravila
koja ima uređenu funkcionisanu državu
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanja države
koja su, pod jednom čelom,
subordinacija i koordinacija.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koju imamo državno,
daj je na različitom stepenu vlasti.
Koordinacija ima isti stepen vlasti
i saradnje.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje. Kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenućemo sa ljudima da vidimo
koji to ljudi rade, šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos
prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini sve stanovništvo,
taj državni aparat čine samo neki ljudi.
Ti ljudi koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenicima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime i za račun države.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određeni poslovi.
Zato
da imate određeno državno službeno lice,
date mu da radi neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu
radu. Uvod u srpskom jeziku je najprostije
i najbolje objašnjeno.
Uzmeš posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom licu
i kažeš da je to tvoja nadležnost.
Postoje dve vrste nadležnosti, u principu
i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
organa, ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno službeno lice,
da li oni rade isto?